seguramente cuando piensa en una
computadora imaginan algo así pero
déjenme decirles que estamos rodeados de
muchas otras computadoras pero no las
vemos lavarropas ascensores equipos
médicos autos todos tienen
algún tipo de inteligencia electrónica
un cerebro al que llamamos computadoras
por ejemplo en un navarro para de alguna
manera nosotros lo programamos para que
cargue agua para que a un lavado algún
enjuague vuelva a cargar agua lavado
jugada el centrifugado eso lo hace un
programa que está adentro de lavarropas
en una computadora con un ascensor según
en qué piso estamos qué botón tocamos
estamos subiendo o bajando
hay una computadora que decide qué es lo
que tiene que hacer
y en algún sentido la computadora de
lavarropas y el sensor short son
parecidas y hay otras computadoras que
tiene que ser más robustas como por
ejemplo en un equipo médico donde está
en juego la vida de una persona o en un
semáforo que si tiene que dar una luz
roja y de pronto una luz verde pues
causa un accidente o el sistema
electrónico de frenos de un auto
o el caso como por ejemplo en un equipo
petrolero que quizás está
horas o incluso días de viaje de la
ciudad más cercana entonces no puede
fallar porque no pudiera repararlo todo
el tiempo
y la pregunta es
quien dice ni estas computadoras quienes
fabrican tienes programa
y la verdad es que nuestro país muchas
veces dependemos de computadoras que son
fabricadas en el exterior que son
importadas o sea dependemos de otros y
esto hace que muchas empresas argentinas
desean no utilizar electrónica cuando
podrían utilizarla para mejorar sus
productos o sus procesos productivos hay
otras que deciden sigue utilizando sus
desarrollos viejos obsoletos
y hay algunas que optan por usar
electrónica importada y dependen de
otros son muy pocas las que se animan a
desarrollar sus propias soluciones
electrónicas
y con un grupo de gente hace un poco
menos de un año
nos pusimos de acuerdo para trabajar
para tratar de revertir esta situación
para ayudar a las empresas a las
pequeñas y medianas empresas de nuestro
país y ustedes pensarán que somos todos
premios nobel
expertos de la nasa pero no déjenme
decirles que somos estudiantes
ingenieros empresarios comunicadores
diseñadores
estamos distribuidos por todo el país
eso implica que hay gente que tiene
distinta forma de vida
y son muy jóvenes ya promedio es de más
o menos 30 años
y me hubiese gustado poner una foto
donde puedan ver a todo el grupo decenas
y decenas de personas pero la verdad es
que no tengo porque hay mucha de esta
gente que nunca se vio en su vida quizás
nunca se conozca quizás nunca se vea
porque trabajan por internet
compartiendo archivos por email por
skype y sin embargo así vamos trabajando
y entre todos hicimos la cia o sea a la
computadora industrial abierta argentina
que es que tengo que a mi mano
computadoras se les dije por qué
industrial también ya les dije
y abierta porque porque toda la
documentación toda la información como
está hecha de cómo se hace y demás y
trato de publicar en internet cualquiera
la puede bajar y la puede utilizar
libremente
podemos decir que la cia no tiene
secretos
y
y esto que implica implica que por
ejemplo una empresa si necesita usar una
computadora por ejemplo para un proceso
productivo puede ir y comprar una a
alguien que la venda y sabes que no
depende de esa persona porque el día de
mañana se puede comprar un tercero o se
puede hacer esa misma o por ejemplo si
tienes que hacer una máquina que sea una
computadora
puede decir bueno yo me la fabricó por
mi cuenta o puede por ejemplo decir yo
me bajo a la información la modificó
como quiero esto es libre y hace su
propia versión que les sirva a su propio
caso y eso implica
que genera trabajo qué
que genera riqueza valor agregado a
nuestro país
y existen en el mundo otras computadoras
abiertas pero que por lo general están
soportadas por una empresa una empresa
multinacional que fabrica los circuitos
integrados los chips y lo hace como la
estrategia de marketing y siempre queda
atado uno a
la al chip de esa empresa en cambio
nosotros como no dependemos de ninguna
empresa multinacional tenemos distintas
versiones basadas en distintos
procesadores lo que significa que somos
libres de verdad no dependemos de
ninguna empresa en particular
pero además esta computadora que tengo
acá en mi mano
es la primera computadora abierta
industrial está pensada desde el
comienzo para ser utilizada en
aplicaciones industriales
entonces qué es esto en definitiva son
circuitos son programas la plaqueta
y cómo se hace bueno viene una persona
dice bueno yo hago esto otro dice ok yo
hago aquello otro dice yo los ayudo mi
trabajo en todo esto es coordinar eso
e incluso hay empresas pequeñas empresas
argentinas que son competidores en un
determinado nicho pero que se dan cuenta
que si participan y colaboran una va a
vender un poco más una vender todavía
más quizás pero todos van a crecer por
lo que lo que crece es la industria
nacional
y para hacer esto
no tenemos un manual una receta porque
es algo que nunca antes se hizo en
ningún lugar del mundo
entonces aprendemos a medida que hacemos
y esto está basado en el trabajo
colaborativo voluntario son personas que
no cobran por hacer esto que quizás lo
hacen a la noche cuando volverá del
trabajo a sus casas o el fin de semana o
algunos tienen la suerte que el trabajo
les permiten hacerlo
y
sin embargo si sumamos las horas
invertidas en esto calculamos que se
llevan invertidos más de 10 millones de
pesos
y donde se utiliza esto bueno por
ejemplo se están haciendo aplicaciones
para equipos médicos para equipos
ferroviarios equipos industriales para
la industria del petróleo para el agro
y además algo muy importante para
nosotros es que hay una red atrás de más
de 50 facultades de ingeniería de todo
el país que son prácticamente todas las
facultades que hay en el país que
enseñan electrónica que venimos
trabajando
y la idea es que a partir del mes de
marzo del año que viene en todas estas
facultades se empezó a utilizar esta
plataforma para enseñar qué es una forma
de difundir esto y además es una forma
que se lo pueden apropiar todos
y esto es un sueño es la primera
computadora industrial abierta argentina
hay gente que
hay gente que deja su huella con cosas
geniales como un cuadro un libro
música
nosotros somos ingenieros
nuestra
nuestra magia nuestro arte es hacer
cosas concretas como esta computadora
muchas gracias